今日はどうキター始めたなぁ
ニコリっこにっこにークリコすき家大好き
皆様端に行こう
おっとすまでさえてまいります外れ車窓の実験室ですお前等キャンるー秋がキャンドゥ
は10歳になるとねもうみんなこぞってキャンプはダメだと思うスキャンブーンから
キャンドゥの中のやっぱ中心架空に入るものはやっぱり12になっちゃうんですよ何か
と言うそう
チュッパチャップスですキパそっぷすずっぱチャップス
こちらです
ん
me
から出すのがめんどくせんだはぁ
はいこちらでございます
コレを待ってたんだよこれをし
これねー
ウォッシャーチュッパチャップス釣りを買いましたわー
第4位で今回はですねまぁこのチュッパチャップス釣りなんですけど
135入ってるんでまあチュッパチャップス街の135こちらでありますさあまあ
一般人版は普通にこれを1歩ずつとってさ
って食べてこう食べるでしょ
1日皇居が4か月くらい持ちましたよけど俺みたいな天才科学者になると人間の
スピードではちょっと耐えられないかもありましたちまちまちまちまペロペロペロペロ
舐めてる暇があったら俺はもう他のことしたいんですよ
そう検索路線今日は何がしたいかというとですねもったいない人僕はあんまり雨が好き
じゃないんですよんで今日はですね今日はこのチップショップとねすぐに全部食べる
いる方法が実験的にやってみようと思いますまたまとめて口に放り込んでバカみたいな
ことすると思うでしょ
合わないんだよ用意するものはこちら
バーカまあです分布ちょっと力ずく感が出ちゃうんですけども判断を使って1個ずつ
粉砕して言ってそれを粉末状にしてさっと流し込むっていう
ん
糖尿病になるかなじゃあさっそくやってることも
ああっん
ながすげーもったいない気がするわ普通に1個ずつ食べたい美味しいものだってやれよ
あーーやてぃんでしょ
やれよ俺がブーブー to do 食べたいせマジですっ
バーッ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
う
うんちょっとねぇ粉みじんなこっぱみじんですただ俺の部屋中がやばいこのなら気に
なる
掃除ちゃんとすればいいかいけるぞおっっに生きるはどんどん来いこれまず135一気
にピョン椅子
袋のままでもいけますねこれあんたので感じていい遊び方だよ
ん
ええええええ
ble bl
ちょっと行われている h します
ラストです
ええええええ
やっぱり103で僕は多い州ちょっと笑ってこれと併せからさあ全部でこれくらいの量
ですちょっと多いしてちなみに床はこんな感じです
生まれで人がの星蔵王きなものを犠牲に何とかできました
こんな感じですわかりますでしょうか
なんじゃねぇ
ちょっと原宿っぽい軽いポンカンっぽい感じがしますねファッションモンスターね2分
全部'思えばいけるんですけどちょっとね登場的な問題が大きい
戯れる一口食ってみましょ
あんま甘い香町大石めっちゃおいしいよこれ
10カチャっとさだぞも美味しいからでは全部混ぜると最高に美味しいいえばネット
サーティ部のポッピングシャワーみたいなしますこれ藪ご飯がススムは
うめぇけど
ハンパなく餃子多い暗雲がまだ虫歯になり阿部ないしもっともっと人生に甘いもの食べ
たいので
ちょっとここは出ております俺はねぇもうなんか敵とリトミックなんとかなんかそこら
へんをちょっとシリアユーチューバーに郵送しておきますじゃあ
ハミガキカメしなきゃって
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
犬月ヒーター
ています
でキャーたプジョーな甘い恋だって部分はから